[Musique]
ça fait longtemps que je pense au
boulanger en particulier et que j'agis
pour eux et pour les entrepreneurs en
général les boulangers spécifiquement
ils ont véritablement deux fois plus de
problèmes que les autres donc la crise
qui traverse d'abord j'ai à cœur de dire
qu'on va pas batailler c'est une vraie
crise ils ont la double peine ça fait
des mois pas que à cause de la guerre en
Ukraine aussi parce que après la crise
du covid la machine économique du monde
est repartie et donc tout le monde a
réenchaîné en même temps et donc il y a
commencé à avoir de l'inflation les prix
ont commencé à augmenter on va pas se
mentir avant aussi la guerre en Ukraine
et ça vous l'avez déjà dit sur votre
plateau les boulangers déjà ils ont vu
le beurre le sucre les œufs je pense aux
amandes pour la galette la farine
augmenter mais pas de 1 ou 2% de 15 20
jusqu'à 28% pour le beurre et ça ça fait
des mois pour pas dire plus d'un an en
parallèle est arrivé la crise de
l'énergie qui s'est amplifiée depuis
début février enfin pu la gare en
Ukraine et ils ont les deux mais il y a
un truc qu'il faut pas oublier non plus
c'est que les boulangers contrairement à
ce qu'on pourrait croire ils sont soumis
à une rude concurrence aussi bien sûr et
notamment celle des hypermarchés des
supermarchés qui font des baguettes ou
des pains des prix inférieurs à 1 €.
donc ils ont la triple Pen ils ont des
charges qui explosent des matières
premières qui explosent et la
concurrence qui est toujours là alors
donc il est normal que je me sois
d'abord saisi du problème des boulangers
c'est urgent qu'on est élargi le
problème sur les TPE et qu'on est aussi
des aides pour les PME mais leur
situation est particulièrement difficile
justement merci d'avoir fait ce
préambule madame la ministre parce que
c'est vrai que c'est important de de
poser les choses et ce soir on va avoir
des réponses on veut savoir si les
boulangers il y en a pour qui c'est déjà
trop tard il y en a on en a reçu ici qui
ont déjà fermé qui malheureusement moi
j'ai eu un boulanger ici qui m'a dit
voilà je vais faire un autre métier il a
dû fermer sa boulangerie il y a de ça
trois semaines
aujourd'hui on est Bruno merci d'être là
Bruno merci et vous êtes en face de
Madame la mini je pense que c'est un
moment important pour vous c'est ce
qu'on pense vous êtes un petit peu le
représentant de tous les boulangers qui
doivent manger
tous les boulangers ils veulent savoir
eux si ils vont pouvoir être sauvés ou
pas donc voilà c'est tout simplement ça
c'est quoi votre situation aujourd'hui
la situation moi je suis impacté depuis
trois septembre c'est installé à Vierzon
d'accord il y avait une petite
boulangerie
boulangerie depuis quatre ans quatre ans
alors je suis une PME j'ai 20 salariés
très bien ouais c'est voilà et je suis
impacté depuis le 3 septembre où on a
été obligé de changer le contrat qui se
renouvelait et où mon mégawater est
passé de 111 euros à 860 euros 860 euros
donc ça vous fait des factures de
combien ça fait que la prochaine facture
qui arrive le 15 là
l'année dernière elle était de 4008 là
elle sera de 24000
24000 euros donc là même si vous vendez
2000 baguettes
par heure ça passe pas ça passe pas la
dernière qui est que j'ai payé que j'ai
payé au mois de décembre elle était de
3008 l'année dernière j'ai donné 18000
celle d'avant vous êtes dans le comment
on fait ben on se débrouille juste oui
oui c'est ce que je disais la dernière
fois vous avez été vous avez dû puiser
dans vos réserves c'est ça et bien sûr
puiser dans les réserves pour les payer
les bien sûr un truc de fou c'est ça
qu'on se dit et comme tous mes collègues
boulanger tous les collègues
boulangerie on travaille pour EDF c'est
tout ce qu'on fait donc 18000 24000
après 24000 avant et au 15 octobre elle
était de 3000 et on a donné 11000
et celle qui était du mois de septembre
elle était 2100 on a donné 5002 mais
comment combien de temps on peut tenir
comme ça pas longtemps
en travaillant en plus j'ai deux
personnes qui sont partis qu'on a pas
remplacé donc c'est moi qui fait le
travail et mon personnel parce que
malheureusement aujourd'hui ça se ça
retombe sur tout le monde et comme l'a
dit Madame ma ministre toutes les
matières premières qui ont des matières
premières alors le beurre c'est pas 25%
c'est x 2 c'est en gros de 6 euros à 14
euros le kilo donc voilà la farine
beaucoup la farine tout enfin tout tout
tout voilà et encore aujourd'hui
vous avez oublié vous avez une PME de de
20 environ donc c'est une belle
boulangerie vous travaillez pour zéro
oui c'est ça pour moi vous êtes en
négatifs
et au jour d'aujourd'hui on a des
boulangers qui leur contrats arrivent à
terme très rapidement moi j'ai des amis
des jeunes sur sur Bourges là qui ce
mois-ci à la fin du mois vont passer de
1500 à 10000
donc à la fin du mois c'est
bien sûr
bien sûr un moment vous êtes posé la
question ou pas on se pose pas la
question parce que on doit des sous à
des banques et puis que il va bien
falloir rembourser tous les prêts qu'on
a donc en plus il va bien sûr il y a le
pré mais il y a tout il y a tout ça
vous avez des prix voilà pour tout voilà
on a pas fait ça pour ça quoi et après
on pense aussi aux jeunes qu'on a qu'on
nous a demandé de former il y a pas si
longtemps on nous a demandé d'emplir les
les centres de formation parce qu'il
fallait former former former au jour
d'aujourd'hui les CFA sont pleins et au
jour d'aujourd'hui les jeunes que qu'on
a formé qu'on leur a dit venez voir dans
notre beau métier vous allez pouvoir
devenir votre propre patron et vivre de
votre de votre travail à condition de
faire 15 heures par jour et au jour
d'aujourd'hui on leur dit la même chose
mais à la fin on leur dit vous allez
travailler juste pour EDF et ben comme
disent nos jeunes ça vend pas du rêve
c'est sûr qu'est-ce que vous avez à dire
à Madame miss qui nous fait l'honneur
d'être là ce soir
ça a sauvé 80% des boulangers qui vont
fermer dans l'année
alors madame Amy c'est vrai que là on le
voit parce que chaque mois qui passe
c'est c'est un drame et c'est vrai que
moi aussi voilà sur ce que je vois sur
ce plateau à chaque fois je me dis
comment on peut les aider donc vous
voulez absolument que vous veniez ce
soir voilà on voit Bruno là il a payé
lorsque vous m'avez dit j'ai calculé
peut-être plus de 35000 € de
d'électricité on a déjà donné
22000 euros de plus le DF que l'année
dernière
comment comment on peut faire pour moi
je veux je vous dis peut-être des
bêtises mais je me suis dit à l'époque
j'avais j'avais proposé j'ai dit est-ce
que on peut pas faire pour l'instant
comme on est dans vraiment dans une
situation exceptionnelle la guerre on
l'avait pas prévu on a eu il y a eu le
covid avant il y a eu énormément de
problèmes comme vous l'avez dit la
situation exceptionnelle est-ce qu'on
peut pas dire qui vendent à prix coûtant
pour l'instant et les fournisseurs
est-ce que c'est possible parce que le
gouvernement a les moyens de le faire ou
est-ce que c'est impossible alors moi je
suis la ministre des Entreprises des
commerces des artisans et du tourisme je
suis pas les spécialistes mon de
l'énergie ce que j'entends on va
apprendre deux trois aimants 860 euros
le megawattheure c'est aberrant et je
reste très poli parce que je suis une
ministre mais c'est la réalité ok déjà
vous vous avez une PME ce qui est d'une
vingtaine de salariés c'est ce que vous
me disiez
nous moi j'ai déjà batailler depuis des
mois et ça a été annoncé vendredi pour
faire en sorte que les plus petits parce
qu'il y a beaucoup de TPE chez les
boulangers de moins de 10 salariés que
les plus petits qui sont très exposées
parce que nous boulangers ils ont des
fours donc ils sont plus exposés que
d'autres entreprises et d'autres
artisans ils soient protégés avec un
tarif qu'on a garanti à 280 euros le
mégawattheure ce que je veux dire déjà
c'est vous avez moins de 10 salariés
vous êtes un boulanger vous allez avoir
des la prochaine facture un tarif qui va
être bloqué pas au dessus de 280 euros
le megawattheure sa première chose que
je vais lui dire non mais il va me dire
ça me concerne pas il aura bien raison
ça on s'est engagé avec les fournisseurs
je vais pas rentrer sur les débats des
fournisseurs on les a pressurisés ils
ont accepté de le faire pour toutes les
TPE de France les toutes petites
entreprises que vous soyez boulanger
bouchées fleurissent blanchisseur on en
parle pas beaucoup mais il souffre aussi
ça va être le cas dès le mois prochain
donc ça c'est pour nos petits vous vous
êtes une PM je veux dire les choses il
en demeure pas moins que même avant
salarié 860 euros le mégawattheure c'est
pas une option donc vous il va falloir
qu'on vous accompagne quand je dis 11
c'est l'état et j'aurai l'occasion de le
dire dans chaque préfecture il y a un
être humain je parle pas d'un site web
ou d'un répondeur zéro licencié je sais
pas quoi un être humain on en parlera
tout à l'heure dans chaque préfecture de
France le site impôts gouv.fr à ce
document sur sa page d'accueil sur ce
tableau vous avez dans chaque
département de France un conseiller pour
vous aider à sortir de la crise il y a
leur 06 donc c'est précis alors mail il
y a leur 06 il faut que et on le fera
dans les prochains jours qu'avec le
conseiller qui va vous aider à sortir de
cette crise parce qu'on va s'en sortir
on va il faut qu'on renégocie votre 860
euros le mégawattheure parce que c'est
pas une option ça on va le renégocier
avec le médiateur de l'énergie je veux
pas employer des mots de technocrates
mais ça peut aller assez vite ça peut
aller assez vite en tout cas ça peut
aller vite pour la facture qui vous
arrive qui est impossible à plus de
22000 euros pour que vous ayez pas à la
payer c'est pas possible la deuxième
chose que je veux vous dire c'est qu'en
tant que PME vous avez des aides
il y a deux choses 1 il y a une aide qui
est pratique vous avez rien à faire si
ce n'est d'aller sur ce même site des
impôts c'est toujours sur la page
d'accueil il y a écrit amortisseur
énergie électricité sur votre facture
vous êtes une PME vous avez une petite
attestation qui est pas compliqué où on
vous demande en vote qualité de
dirigeant est-ce que vous êtes une PME
si vous êtes une PME vous aurez une
ristourne de environ 20% sur la facture
dès le mois prochain je suis pas dans
six mois le mois prochain on la voit ici
amortisseur électricité 20% direct ça va
pas ça va pas sauver il en faut plus
c'est ça c'est pour ça que sur ce même
site le même vous avez vous souvenez du
fond de solidarité
tous les deux mois vous envoyez un truc
et vous bénéficiez du fond de solidarité
même principe votre comptable c'est le
faire vous avez possibilité au moment où
je vous parle de vous faire aider sur
les factures de septembre octobre vous
aurez possibilité dès lundi vous faire
aider déposer les demandes
pour Novembre Décembre
l'amortisseur la ristourne plus ce que
je vous ai dit sur les aides qui sont
sur ce site ça va représenter sur votre
cas qui est énorme en termes de hausse à
peu près 30 % de prise en charge direct
de la facture par l'État
on va en parallèle renégocier le contrat
il faut qu'on renégocie le contrat et le
conseiller dont j'ai parlé dans le 06 et
sur le site des impôts pas derrière un
onglet caché sur la homepage des impôts
on va le mettre à nos côtés pour pouvoir
renégocier votre contrat après j'entends
ce que vous dites vous savez moi je
viens pas de l'administration j'ai été
plus longtemps dans le privé et petite
entrepreneur et salarié que ministre
vous avez aussi ce qu'on appelle un BFR
un besoin en fond de roulement qui est
énorme votre trésorerie elle est à plat
et donc j'entends bien qu'on critique
quand on dit je mets des délais de
paiement j'entends bien qu'on critique
quand je dis je décale l'URSSAF je
décale vos impôts parce que je résous
pas le problème je le décale le problème
n'empêche que je redonne du souffle à la
trésorerie il y a un truc qu'il faut
dire sur ce plateau l'État
va proposer à toutes les PME de décaler
toutes les charges ok pour qu'on arrive
à faire à passer ces mois difficiles qui
sont c'est moi heure pleine hiver dans
une facture il y a quatre sortes
d'heures vous le savez vous lisez vos
factures mais décalez
la troisième solution d'accord j'ai
parlé de deux aides et j'ai jamais dit
qu'en décalant résolvait je vends pas de
la carabine on décale on leur redonne un
peu de souffle en trésorerie vous n'y
arrivez toujours pas on va trouver une
solution avec le conseiller qu'on
appelle sortie de crise le conseiller
dont vous avez les coordonnées là on va
trouver une solution ce que je veux dire
c'est que il fait quoi de sa facture à
chaque fois vous je ne sais pas si vous
voulez est-ce que vous avez appelé EDF
ah oui alors on a appelé EDF alors je
suis désolé de se voir
quand on la personne que vous parlez
dans mon département je l'ai appelé je
la connais et il se trouve que c'est
même une client et au jour d'aujourd'hui
elle a pas un grandes solution c'est
dames et malgré toute sa bonne volonté
et nous dit que on a ce qu'ils ont là et
aujourd'hui s'il faut impérativement que
on puisse renégocier nos contrats avec
des tarifs normaux mais si on arrive si
on arrivait
aujourd'hui quand on appelle EDF il nous
disent non monsieur
alors bien sûr parce qu'on a pris un
engagement on a peu de temps donc
j'imagine que vous avez signé un contrat
à la rentrée dernière j'imagine que vous
avez signé quand les prix étaient très
hauts j'imagine que c'est possiblement
un contrat qui est pas très long on va
pas se mentir
ça ça doit être négocié bien sûr voilà
alors on est avec Pierre marit ici
également restaurateur vous calez votre
situation aujourd'hui alors ma situation
est notre situation parce que là aussi
je parle en mon nom mais je représente
quand même surpression notre situation
est un petit peu différente madame la
ministre vous parlez de triple Pen tout
à l'heure
nous c'est une double donc c'est
peut-être plus facile à résoudre
hiérarchie dans la souffrance grosse
double peine et je suis obligé de
revenir un petit peu en arrière puisque
nous nous avons été extrêmement impactés
par la crise covid ce qui était
restaurateur moins le cas de nos amis
les boulangers et tant mieux pour eux
j'ai une jalousie dans ce que je dis
mais c'est une réalité nous on a
énormément souffert à titre d'exemple
moi j'ai perdu un an de chiffre
d'affaires sur trois ans disons que sur
les l'année 2020 2021 2022 globalement
c'est un an de chiffre d'affaires qui
est parti que que je n'ai pas que ce
n'est pas engrangé je fais un peu plus
d'un million de chiffre d'affaires
j'emploie
24 personnes disons en équivalent temps
plein sur deux sociétés différentes
puisque j'ai un hôtel un restaurant et
un centre équestre et donc l'ensemble et
PME de environ 20 voilà 26 27 personnes
environ sur l'ensemble de l'année
le covid qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
la première année on n'a pas eu d'aide
on peut dire que les aides elles étaient
très marginales la première année on a
eu le droit d'emprunter mais c'est comme
ça qu'on a passé le cap de la première
année donc on a eu ce fameux PGE dont
tout le monde parle alors je sais que
voilà c'est c'est
[Musique]
on parle toujours du pyjama on a un
petit peu marre d'entendre le péché le
seul problème c'est que c'est maintenant
que les choses se passent puisque c'est
maman
donc alors
il vaut mieux avoir vécu le covid en
France qu'aux États-Unis jusqu'au 46
c'est vrai que il y a eu on a tout dit
sur le PGE entre autres entre autres
spécieux d'ailleurs que j'aime bien
appeler poison garanti par l'État pardon
de cette expression un peu un peu
vulgaire mais c'est un petit peu ça
c'est comme ça qu'on le ressent
on a eu on a cru espérer pendant la
campagne électorale et je fais pas de
politique en disant ça mais je j'écoute
simplement que cette dette qui n'est pas
une dette d'exploitation c'est un
emprunt qu'on a dû prendre pour rester
un survivre trésorerie en fait ça ne
sert pas dans nos investissements ça
n'est pas utile ça ne diminue pas nos
charges ça n'augmente pas de chiffre
d'affaires c'est un crédit de trésorerie
important moi j'ai emprunté 300000 euros
parce que j'avais besoin de ces 300000 €
et j'ai croqué les 300000 euros parce
que j'en ai eu besoin et aujourd'hui
vous voulez remboursez là alors moi je
commence à les rembourser ça fait 6 mois
que j'ai rembourse et je ne peux pas les
rembourser ça alors qu'aujourd'hui c'est
ajouter les problèmes dont on vient de
parler dont on vient de parler
exactement le problème d'énergie il faut
quand même considérer si pour être très
simple
le remboursement du PGE c'est 6 points
de marge en 6 à 7 points de marche
environ en moyenne dans la profession à
25% de de de du chiffre d'affaires
emprunté sous forme de PGE ça représente
sur trois ça représente 6 à 7%
la revanisation de la grille salariale
très importante il faut le faire je suis
un il faut le dire sur le dire il faut
le faire il faut le dire à ceux qui
disent que vous avez pas augmenter les
salaires parce que dans l'hôtellerie
vous avez beaucoup augmenté nous moi ça
moi ça va me coûter 9 l'augmentation
c'est pas 15 % normalement c'est 15 %,
moi c'est l'augmentation va être de 9 %,
parce que on était déjà un petit peu au
dessus de la grille donc
ça veut dire que ça va me coûter 6 % de
marge donc 6 pour le PGE 6 pour
l'augmentation de salaire et à cela je
rajoute l'énergie donc les DF moi en ce
qui me concerne je suis beaucoup plus
chanceux que mon confrère boulanger
puisque mon augmentation mon coefficient
n'est que de 4 non commercial je vais
passer de 21000 à
72000 donc
j'ai 70000 euros de remboursement annuel
de PGE et j'ai 70000 euros
d'augmentation d'électricité parce que
on ne parle que de l'électricité mais
j'ai aussi du gaz je suis choqué au gaz
et le gaz il est doublé c'est
coefficient de donc je passe de le gaz
de 13000 à 26000 euros donc comment dans
une dans un commerce dans lequel on
gagne très peu d'argent on est d'accord
moi je suis en province je suis à la
campagne je suis dans le département de
l'Allier c'est merveilleux c'est très
beau et cetera mais je suis pas ni dans
une zone
je suis pas sur la Côte d'Azur je suis
pas dans une station de montagne je suis
comme beaucoup de mes confrères dans
dans le tiroir dans dans le tourisme
vert avec une forte saisonnalité et bien
je je gagne peut-être deux trois pour
cent les bonnes années de 3% de marge à
peu près ça le standard de 3% de marge
là il faut que je sorte 18% de marge je
peux pas je ne peux pas donc je suis
confronté à une impossibilité et je ne
sais pas ce qui va se passer madame la
ministre donc il va se passer quoi pour
vous et bien moi je d'abord le PGE pour
l'instant je rembourser jusqu'à présent
donc j'ai déjà remboursé 40000 euros de
PGE donc c'est 40000 euros que je n'ai
pas dans mes caisses au passage j'ai
emprunté à titre personnel 40000 euros
pour remettre dans mon entreprise donc
finalement c'est moi mes prêts
personnels qui rembourse le PG ce qui
est ce qui est insensé ça n'a plus de
sens on est dans une dans une sorte
d'économie qui est juste complètement
ubuesque décalé aujourd'hui quand vous
allez vous en sortir vous allez voir
alors bah écoutez on a il y a des
dispositifs quand même un ami va
certainement le dire on peut négocier
c'est ce qu'on appelle les médiations
mais la médiation c'est c'est un piège
pardon de le dire
je suis obligé de négocier c'est-à-dire
que il va falloir que je trouve c'est
gagner du temps pour mettre autour de la
table le la Banque de France les les
banques auxquelles j'ai souscrit des
emprunts donc en partie mon PGE et puis
mes fournisseurs mais auprès de qui je
n'ai personnellement aucune dette donc
mes soldes c'est vis-à-vis des banques
il va falloir qu'on se mette d'accord
pour
je ne peux pas m'empêcher de vous poser
la question pourquoi pourquoi doit-on
rembourser ce PGE pourquoi ma question
il suffirait de supprimer le PSG déjà
pour sauver ces gens là qu'est-ce que
vous avez entendu pour les banques vous
avez dit ce que vous avez entendu lors
de l'élection présidentielle
souvenez-vous le débat de d'Emmanuel
Macron et et et Marine Le Pen la
remontée du du du PGE dans les quasi
fonds propres
avaient été avancé
il y a eu un dépôt de bois à antérieur
ça il y avait un dépôt de loi qui avait
été fait par l'UDI en une semaine
alors déjà j'ai à coeur de rappeler que
tout est toujours possible donc après
c'est les choix politiques et des
décisions politiques
le PGE c'est à peu un peu plus de 150
milliards d'euros
ce qui est important que je partage avec
vous sans être trop casse-pied c'est que
la situation
économique du monde elle a changé entre
2000 et 2023 vous êtes des chefs
d'entreprise vous êtes des particuliers
vous savez ce que c'est un taux
d'intérêt quand vous achetez une voiture
quand vous achetez vous rénovez une
boulangerie les taux d'intérêt quand on
a fait les PGE ils étaient négatifs les
taux d'intérêt ce soir on se parle ils
ont dépassé les 3% entre Noël et le
Jourdain c'est-à-dire que quand
t'emprunte 1000 euros ça coûte beaucoup
plus cher aujourd'hui que ça te coûtait
en 2020 vous avez dit quelque chose
auquel je suis très sensible je le redis
j'ai été plus entrepreneur que le
ministre on est dans un système non mais
je vous garantis que je réponds aux
questions moi donc le PG je vais
répondre pourquoi pourquoi parce que 150
milliards de dettes aujourd'hui avec des
taux d'intérêt comme on les a et merci
de me relancer ce serait irresponsable
et je vais vous dire pourquoi parce que
vous me diriez à ce moment-là dans deux
trois ans madame Grégoire vous avez fait
n'importe quoi la dette est là explosé
et on est sorti des clous du déficit
totalement nos taux d'intérêt regardez
la Grande-Bretagne on bondit alors là
pour aller réemprunter avec des taux à
6% c'est costaud et surtout vous me
diriez en gros vous avez dilapidé notre
argent et quand il y a des dettes c'est
valable pour l'État aussi il y a qu'un
moyen de la remonter c'est les impôts et
si les impôts des entreprises ou les
impôts des particuliers et ça on n'a pas
touché on a fait des bêtises on n'a pas
tout fait bien s'il y a un truc quand
même qu'on a fait depuis 2017 et sur
lequel je raconte pas des âneries c'est
baisser les impôts sur les sociétés des
impôts de production et ça on veut pas
travailler notre promesse on veut pas
augmenter les impôts donc aujourd'hui
tirer un trait bien sûr que c'est
tentant sur 150 milliards de PC
non
je vais y répondre les 150 milliards ce
serait
irresponsable que de les rayer d'un coup
qu'on vous donne plus de temps qu'on
puisse rééchelonner sur deux ans sur
quatre ans c'est tout à fait normal plus
plus long et actuellement c'est
quasiment impossible de le faire alors
sauf sur des conditions qui sont
drastiques c'est-à-dire que
la Banque de France je suis pas d'accord
avec ça une entreprise à risque
c'est-à-dire que vous avez en
fournisseurs qui vont vous demander de
payer au cul du camion vous allez avoir
vos banques qui voudront plus vous
prêter de l'argent et donc vous ne
pourrez plus continuer à rénover les
établissements c'est ça
ou la conciliation c'est ça va aboutir
c'est un sujet fermé c'est un sujet très
important moi je vous dis madame la
ministre j'ai créé cette affaire il y a
il y a 23 ans j'ai 68 ans aujourd'hui
j'ai au passage aujourd'hui l'âge de
prendre ma retraite ce que je n'ai pas
l'intention de faire ceci étant je n'ai
pas non plus l'intention de galérer
pendant des années vous n'avez pas
le mien c'est ça mon souci il sait pas
le mien de c'est quand même en fait si
on prend une image c'est quand même un
emprunt on a mis toutes l'économie sur
respiration artificielle c'est un
emprunt qui a quand même permis de tenir
nos boîtes et qu'elle réouvre en 2021
quand le covid est reparti c'est un
emprunt qu'on peut rééchelonner dans le
temps je suis pas d'accord sur ce que
vous dites sur le marquage des banques
déjà j'en profite pour faire passer un
message vous faites un million d'euros
de chiffre d'affaires donc vous vous
avez ce qu'on appelle une cotation FIBEN
permettez-moi de passer un message aux
entrepreneurs qui font moins de 750 000
euros de chiffre d'affaires il n'y a pas
de marquage pour les entreprises qui
font moins de 750 000 euros de chiffre
d'affaires on a assez de raison d'avoir
peur de plein de trucs pour pas se faire
peur là-dessus mais vous vous êtes un
lien donc vous avez un marquage moi
d'abord j'ai à coeur de vous rappeler
que ce marquage il va pas durer 5 ans
pas duré 10 ans il va durer 12 mois 18
mois je tente les échéanciers soient
passés il y a une chose parce que je
vous entends le sentiment aussi que vous
avez envie de continuer à investir dans
votre entreprise pour moderniser votre
outil de travail faire évolu votre hôtel
bon mais vous êtes aussi un entrepreneur
moi je l'ai été je comprends que quand
on a déjà une dette à rembourser on vous
engage pas non plus dans d'autres types
d'emprunts d'investissement parce que ça
ça vous coule si vous n'arrivez pas à
rembourser un PG2 de 70 000 ou 80.000
euros par an c'est ce serait
irresponsable que la banque vous dise
oui sur un emprunt un 500000 alors qu'on
a déjà toutes ces échéances sauf que si
je rembourse 70 à 80000 euros par an
c'est tout simplement parce que cette
empreinte doit être remboursé sur une
durée de 4 ans
est-ce que vous mesurez que l'Europe je
sais il y a des gens qui veulent en
sortir mais est-ce que vous mesurez déjà
que en France on a renégocié avec Bruno
Le Maire de réelonner sur le plus
d'années possible on est un des seuls
pays où tu peux rééchelonner sur 6-8 ans
ton PGE c'est pas le cas dans plein de
pays européens donc je sais que c'est
compliqué quand on demande à une banque
entrepreneurs
qui m'a donné le PGE je leur dis je vous
j'ai besoin de le réel je le connais
je vais vous expliquer je vais vous
expliquer ce qui se passe on demande à
la banque un allongement du PGE on va
dire on va partir sur une durée de huit
années par exemple la banque dit mais
moi j'ai aucun problème pour l'étendre
sur 8 ans la seule chose c'est que je ne
peux pas le faire parce que je perds la
garantie de l'État donc c'est pas le
problème de la banque c'est le problème
de l'État
en tous les cas c'est l'expérience
véhicule si c'est possible avec la
médiation
je ne comprends pas pourquoi l'État ne
continue pas à garantir un PGE qui
serait étendu à 8 ans ou à l'état
garantie l'État a même mis de l'argent
de côté je vais tout vous dire l'état a
même provisionné mis de l'argent de côté
dans le dernier budget vous pouvez
demander à Gabriel Attal pour justement
au cas où on est des défaillances en
chaîne de PGE
de garantie il a été réintégré au budget
de l'État parce qu'aujourd'hui on a un
tiers des frais de garantie par l'État
qui sont remboursés on a moins de 1%
j'ai pas envie de baigner dans trop de
chiffres mais moins de 1 % des pges qui
connaissent des défauts ça veut pas dire
que vous n'êtes pas dans ce cas là c'est
le début mais parce que vous n'en êtes
qu'au début peut-être si la situation
de cohérent moi les aides d'énergie
c'est pas de la dette c'est important de
le dire la principale c'est de problème
aujourd'hui c'est
d'accord tu l'as eu tu vas le rembourser
là on te raquette de 20000 à 40000 euros
mais là le problème c'est pas le player
s'il y avait pas eu l'augmentation
électricité le pêche que il lâche
remboursé comme des grands garçons on
leur a prêté 150 000 et les horaires
remboursés ils ne peuvent pas la
rembourser parce qu'on leur met 80000
un prix de l'électricité nationale étant
donné notre avantage dans ce domaine
il faut savoir il faut savoir que
aujourd'hui EDF produit le megawater
entre 40 et 45 euros
en 70 EDF gagnant encore de l'argent et
le prix gros est à 180 alors pourquoi je
sais que c'est un peu quand même
toujours au lendemain tout le monde est
devenu épidémiologique du jour au
lendemain de
de les médias
je n'aurai pas la prétention de faire
une leçon sur le prix du mégawater
parce que c'est un marché et un sujet un
peu complexe moi je suis pas là pour
venir discuter du prix spot de l'avenir
d'EDF du machin je suis là pour vous
dire où sont les aides pour vous les
boulangers les TPE les PME on va rester
un peu sur l'énergie j'ai entendu
monsieur votre interpellation sur le PGE
c'est un vrai sujet moi j'ai un cœur de
dire
deux choses un déjà il y a un effet
panique vous voyez je vais pas vous
embêter mais j'ai des factures en main
tous les jours là elle est anonymisée il
y a des effets paniques et il y a une
chose que je veux partager c'est que ça
n'est pas parce que le prix de votre
mégawattheure fait fois 5 ou x 6 que le
prix de votre facture sur l'année fait
fois 5 ou x 6 nous sommes dans ce qu'on
appelle les heures pleines hiver oui
quand je dis ce sera 280 euros le
mégawattheure garanti sur l'année à
toutes nos toutes petites entreprises il
faut qu'on comprenne qu'il faut pas
paniquer même si c'est paniquant quand
on voit x 10 sur le mégawattheure heure
pleine en plein hiver parce que dès le
printemps dès l'été c'est pris il
chutent et c'est sur la moyenne de
l'année et vous avez déjà payé tout de
suite
j'étais en heure d'été au mois de
septembre et ma facture du 15 octobre
qui était en heure d'été elle a passé de
2100 à 52 quand même oui même en heure
d'été
je vous ai dit et en l'occurrence c'est
on va le faire avec le conseiller à la
sortie de crise que vous avez déjà
contacté je vous en remercie il faut
qu'on casse votre contrat et qu'on en
remette en autre en place après je suis
quelqu'un de très sincère pas tout ce
que vous avez déjà donné et quand vous
me demandiez
ça me serre
de réunion j'ai passé avec les
fournisseurs d'énergie avec Bruno Le
Maire je peux vous dire qu'on a été plus
que clair et qui sont sortis de cette
réunion avec un tarif garanti ce qui
était pas du tout l'idée quand ils sont
rentrés d'accord on lâche pas l'affaire
on ne lâchera pas l'affaire je vous
garantis que 25 30% de votre facture en
direct va être prise en charge pas à la
Saint-Glinglin sur la facture de février
il y aura écrit amortisseur c'est une
ristourne derrière je le redis un
pot.gouv il y a d'autres aides derrière
si ça suffit pas on va trouver des
solutions et si vous l'acceptez monsieur
avec mes services avec mon cabinet mon
équipe au cabinet au ministère on va si
vous l'acceptez se mettre en relation
directe avec la conseillère de la
préfecture pour vous trouver une
solution on trouve des solutions mais il
y a pas que moi
il y a deux choses qu'il faut savoir
mais ça je m'adresse à vous et je
m'adresse par de la vous à tous les
boulons mais au-delà de ça aux artisans
parce que j'aime aussi les bouchers les
blanchisseurs et les fleuristes il y a
pas de raison même si vous êtes plus il
a appelé le conseiller il a dit qu'il y
avait rien à faire ouais mais c'est pour
ça que la famille
je pense que c'est pas le seul donc il y
a plein vous avez pas bien sûr vous avez
pas recevoir tous les tous les non j'ai
qui sont je ne vais pas et je ne peux
pas humainement recevoir ou les
boulangers mais en revanche ce que je
peux faire avec la première ministre
avec Bruno Le Maire qu'on a fait encore
lundi
c'est mettre la pression sur les préfets
et les préfectures pour que il vous
fasse connaître les aides et si ça
suffit pas qu'on trouve des solutions et
s'il faut faire plus monsieur je vais
vous le dire on fera plus quand j'ai été
nommé ministre il y avait pas
d'amortisseur ça fait 6 mois que je suis
là vous aurez une ristourne sur la
facture de février et si ça suffit pas
monsieur moi je prendrai mes
responsabilités pour le dire au
président de la République et la
première ministre qui m'écoute si ça
suffit pas on va s'adapter on a mis
tellement d'argent dans cette crise
covid pour s'en sortir on s'en sort bien
oui c'est dur mais le seul pays d'Europe
qui va avoir une croissance légèrement
au dessus de 0 c'est nous je sais que
c'est dur mais on n'a pas mis des
centaines de milliards d'euros dans le
covid on n'a pas endetté le pays pour
vous planter deux ans après on ne va pas
vous lâcher s'il faut faire plus je vous
le dis dans le droit des yeux que ce
soit sur les PGE s'il faut renégocier
des choses que ce soit sur les aides
parce qu'elles sont pas suffisantes pour
vous on fera plus moi j'ai un message à
dire pendant qu'il y en a qui font du
beurre sur votre dos
beaucoup de politiques beaucoup
d'oppositions qui font leur beurre sur
votre dos plutôt que de vous écrire des
courriers en vous disant vous allez
mourir moi je voudrais qu'on vienne vous
voir peu importe sa couleur politique en
vous disant voilà où sont les aides et
comment vous aide au moment où on se
parle Cyril Hanouna il y a 12 milliards
d'euros sur la table 12 milliards que
pour vous au moment où on se parle ça
fait 4 mois on a des caissé moins de 500
millions d'euros et des mois il faut
qu'on aille chercher cet arbre
tous je dis pas que c'est parfait mais
moi je suis plus forte quand on a on a
si les 12 milliards dans trois mois il y
a plus rien bah moi je suis légitime
pour aller voir Renault
je suis désolé il faut qu'on appelle on
va voir avec votre comptable mais c'est
pas normal moi je les ai regardés
le doigt sur le problème actuellement si
vous il y a 12 milliards sur la table il
y a 500 millions qui ont été utilisés et
on voit donc c'est bon monsieur et ce
monsieur ils sont en galère donc il y a
peut-être un problème voilà de tous les
jours
il y a des boulangers des bouchers des
entrepreneurs alors qu'il y avait 12
milliards d'euros sur la table donc ça
ça c'est vrai que c'est il y a une
personne qu'on appelle tous les mois
enfin si mes souvenirs sont bons quand
on est entrepreneurs c'est son comptable
vous l'appelez tous les mois moi je
travaille avec l'Ordre des
Experts-Comptables de l'autre côté par
exemple pour que vous ayez pas à payer
plus dans votre forfait parce qu'elle va
vous chercher des aides parce que j'ai
ce cas là aussi des gens qui ont 1000
euros d'aide et puis des honoraires de
comptable à 500 euros ça j'ai eu la
présidente du Conseil de l'Ordre des
Experts Comptables elle a été très
responsable pour dire justement aux
experts-comptables ou les aider mais
c'est dans le forfait 1 vous parle pas à
vous mais j'en profite pour parler à
tous ceux qui nous écoutent et qui ont
pas eu le réflexe d'appeler son
comptable un appelez votre comptable 2
je le redis et pardonner la répétition
impôts.gouv.fr je sais que je vais vous
dire un truc avec un peu d'humour même
si le moment s'y prête pas c'est pas
naturel pour un entrepreneur d'aller sur
le site des impôts pour demander de
l'aide je vous l'accorde c'est et je
l'ai demandé hier à Bercy c'est sur la
première page j'avais même pas à galérer
à chercher à cliquer particulier
entreprise et tout vous avez
l'amortisseur je suis une PME je coche
je renvoie à mon fournisseur vous avez
cette liste avec les coordonnées vous
vous avez une réflexe il y a plein de
boulanger qui connaissent pas ces gens
dans les préfectures dans les départs
de votre conseiller départemental de
sortie crise là vous avez pas des des
robots derrière c'est des êtres humains
avec des 06 et je le redis et je vous le
redis au nombre Bruno Le Maire et du
président de la République on ne lâchera
pas si ça suffit pas on fera plus j'ai
quand même à cœur de dire une chose au
moment où on se parle il y a pas un pays
en Europe qui protège auto les citoyens
et les entreprises face à l'inflation
chacun je parle des individus vous moi
en tant que particulier sur votre
facture vous avez vu 20-25 euros en tant
que particulier d'augmentation mesurer
que la même facture en Allemagne c'est
180 170 euros d'augmentation par mois il
y a pas un pays en Europe qui a mis sur
la table 110 milliards depuis octobre 21
pour payer les factures d'énergie des
Français
j'ai vraiment je parle d'argent là qui
est pour le pouvoir d'achat des Français
pour que justement ce que monsieur a
déjà dû faire quand il y a des
augmentations de prix ou puisse
continuer à consommer d'ailleurs la
consommation elle ne s'effondre pas dans
notre pays ça vous a pas échappé on a 12
13% d'inflation dans l'alimentaire j'ai
pas une baisse de la consommation de
12%. donc on a on arrive à résorber en
soutenant le pouvoir d'achat 12
milliards d'euros pour les entreprises
en ce moment je suis en train de vous
dire qu'il y a 122 milliards injectés
dans notre économie pour aider les
particuliers et les entreprises c'est
pas suffisant si c'est pas suffisant on
fera plus il y a pas un pays en Europe
qui a fait ça il y a des Allemands et je
le préviens parce que certains vont le
dire qu'ils disent on mettra 200
milliards d'euros moi je suis une fille
concrète moi je préfère voir
l'amortisseur en février sur vos
factures plutôt que des blablas où on
vous dit il y aura jusqu'à 200 milliards
qui sont pas dans l'économie aujourd'hui
ils sont dans l'économie il faut qu'on
arrive à faire en sorte que les
boulangers de tous les coins de France
les artisans les PME aille chercher ses
aides si on décaisse et que c'est pas
suffisant je vous le dis comme je
m'appelle Olivia Grégoire j'irai
demander plus et j'y mettrai tout mon
poids parce que ma raison d'être moi je
viens pas de la cuisse de Jupiter
pardonner l'expression même si elle est
hasardeuse je viens de l'entretien et
c'est pas pour rien que j'ai accepté ce
ministère et j'en veux aucun autre et je
me battrai jusqu'au bout et je sais
qu'il m'écoutent et s'il faut faire plus
on fera plus mais de grâce déjà allons
chercher ces 12 milliards franchement
parce qu'il y a vos équipes qui veulent
que vous rentriez ça y est
et ils ont dit c'est pas par la cuisse
de Jupiter il faut rentrer merci en tout
cas à vous parce que voilà non mais
c'est la moindre des choses je suis pas
venu pour débattre parce qu'on a peu de
temps je suis venu essayer de vous dire
il y a des solutions c'est ce qu'on
voulait et je suis venu pour vous dire
que que moi je ne ni rien je suis pas
dans le déni je vous raconte pas une
histoire qui est pas la vraie c'est
difficile non mais on va y arriver
voilà que comme je vous disais de la
facture de février c'est 10 février
[Musique]
l'Aristote sur la facose on veut c'est
des dates c'est surtout sur la facture
de fin janvier il y a un truc et il y
aura ce truc là alors elle reviendra
je bouge pas vous venez je suis une
fille poli quand on m'invite je viens je
viens par contre c'est facile même quand
vous n'êtes pas invité c'est ce que font
les autres donc n'hésitez pas ils le
font déjà très bien merci en tout cas